the multi-identity sand dollar lounge
transforms into the miracle on spring
mountain tonight yeah rocky stopped by
to give us a preview
whether you're on the naughty or nice
list you're invited to miracle on spring
mountain a holiday themed pop-up bar at
the sand dollar lounge the miracle
program down here takes about 16 hours
and 30 hands on deck
lots and lots of effort and weeks and
weeks of planning for the cocktails that
we get started for
for the exclusive cocktails i might add
these specialty drinks can only be found
in vegas at miracle bar so the cocktails
this year include
some of our signatures like our santa
rex which comes in a custom ceramic mug
we also have classics like
our jingle bell eggnog this year we're
introducing a couple new ones with some
mulled wine reductions
and we also have a couple hot cocktails
this year we're doing a
hot buttered rum
so spice butter
rum falerinum really delicious
and what's a party without pizza sundays
and wednesdays every week we're going to
have chefs from local restaurants come
down and do pizza pop-ups chefs like
james trees of esther's kitchen and
brian howard of sparrow and wolf we also
get really excited for our pop-ups that
we do for ugly sweater parties like
we're gonna have on the fourth and our
vodka and latkes party that we're
actually gonna have on the 28th of this
month in november
december 13th for grinch night and
december 20th for naughty or nice night
mostly naughty but you know you do you
so make sure to come on down at miracle
on spring mountain we're open 3 p.m to 4
a.m nightly it's first come first serve
21 and over there's never a cover we
have live entertainment such as polly
shore in the crisis they'll be here the
9th of december make sure to come on
that's going to be a crazy show tis the
time to celebrate this twenty thousand
dollar transformation so you can join
the miracle and spring mountain ribbon
cutting tonight at six and get into the
spirit
thank you rocky doors open at six and
it's open through new year's eve he said
paulie shore's gonna be there yeah his
band performs there and i've heard it
gets wild in there that place is a blast
it's so much fun they get so in the
spirit of whatever holiday it is and i
heard rocky say twenty thousand dollars
to transform it into christmas so they
really go all out you saw you saw the
mugs yes so sand dollar lounge that's
that's where the bartenders go to have
their cocktails you know it's a good bar
that when the bartenders go to have
their drinks at the place and you know
it's a good bar when they have a santa
mug that you can get yes absolutely